Mais ce n’est pas uniquement l’Australie qui est en meilleure santé que l’Angleterre.
Au sein même de la Grande-Bretagne, il y a des différences -
– et c’est ce qu’on appelle la mortalité standard, en clair,
vos chances de mourir.
C’est calculé en prenant en compte les données des publications d’il y a 20 ans environ,
mais c’est encore vrai aujourd’hui.
En comparant le taux de mortalité à 50° Latitude Nord --
c’est le sud, c'est Londres et ses environs –
et 55° Latitude Nord
la mauvaise nouvelle c’est que c’est ici, Glasgow.
Je suis d’Edimbourg. Pire nouvelle, c’est même Edimbourg.
(Rires)
Alors qu’est-ce qui est responsable de cet espace horrible ici,
entre nous ici dans le sud de l’Écosse
et le sud ?
Maintenant, tout le monde a entendu parler du tabac,
des barres chocolatées Mars, des frites – le régime de Glasgow.
De toutes ces choses.
Mais ce graphique prend en compte
tous ces facteurs de risques identifiés.
Celui-ci prend en compte le tabagisme, la classe sociale, le régime,
tous les facteurs de risques.
On se retrouve avec un espace manquant
de décès augmenté au fur et à mesure que vous allez au nord.
Donc, le soleil compte, bien sûr.
La Vitamine D a eu très bonne presse
et de nombreuses personnes se sont senties concernées.
Nous avons besoin de vitamine D. Les enfants doivent en avoir une certaine quantité.
Ma grand-mère a grandi à Glasgow,
dans les années 20 -30 quand le rachitisme était un vrai problème
et que l’huile de foie de morue était introduite.
C’était utilisé pour lutter efficacement contre le rachitisme qui était courant dans cette ville.
Quand j’étais petit, j’étais nourri à l’huile de foie de morue par ma grand-mère.
Sérieusement -- personne ne peut oublier l'huile de foie de morue.
Il y a un lien : Plus les gens ont un taux élevé de vitamine D dans le sang,
moins ils ont de maladies cardiaques, de cancer.
Il semble y avoir de nombreuses données suggérant que la vitamine D est très bonne.
Et c'est vrai, pour prévenir du rachitisme et d'autres choses.
Mais si vous donnez aux gens des compléments en Vitamine D
vous ne changez pas ce taux élevé de maladie cardiaque.
Les éléments prouvant l'impact sur la prévention des cancers ne sont pas encore probants.
Ce que je veux dire c'est que la vitamine D n'est pas la seule dans l'histoire.
Ce n'est pas la seule raison pour prévenir les maladies cardiaques.
Des taux élevés de vitamine D, peuvent être, à mon avis, utilisés comme indicateurs de l'exposition au soleil,
et l'exposition au soleil, dans les méthodes que je vais vous montrer
est bonne pour lutter contre les maladies du coeur.
Enfin, je suis revenu d'Australie,
et malgré les risques évidents pour ma santé, j'ai emménagé à Aberdeen.
(Rires)
Ensuite, à Aberdeen, j'ai commencé mon stage en dermatologie.
Je me suis intéressé à la recherche
et je me suis intéressé en particulier à cette substance, l'oxyde nitrique.
Bien, ces trois gars là-haut,
Furchgott, Ignarro et Murad,
ont gagné le Prix Nobel de médecine en 1998.
Ils étaient les premiers à décrire
ce nouveau neurotransmetteur chimique, l'oxyde nitrique.
L'oxyde nitrique dilate les vaisseaux sanguins,
ce qui diminue votre pression sanguine.
ça dilate aussi les artères coronaires, ce qui arrête l'angine.
Ce qui est remarquable à ce propos,
c'est que lorsque l'on pense aux messagers chimiques
on pense à des trucs compliqués, comme l'oestrogène et l'insuline,
ou des neurotransmetteurs.
Des processus très complexes avec des composés très complexes
qui s'adaptent à des récepteurs très complexes.
Et cette molécule incroyablement simple,
un azote et un oxygène qui sont coincés ensemble,
et qui est très importante pour notre pression sanguine basse,
pour la neurotransmission, pour beaucoup, beaucoup de choses,
mais surtout pour la santé cardio-vasculaire.
J’ai commencé à faire des recherches, et nous avons trouvé cela très passionnant,
que la peau produit de l’oxyde nitrique.
Donc ça n’augmente pas uniquement dans le système cardio-vasculaire.
Ça se passe dans la peau.
Nous avons prouvé ça, nous l’avons publié,
je me suis demandé, qu’est-ce que ça fait ?
Comment peut-on avoir une faible pression sanguine dans notre peau ?
Ce n’est pas le cœur… Qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
Je suis ensuite allé aux Etats-unis, comme beaucoup de gens qui font de la recherche,
et j’ai passé quelques années à Pittsburgh. Voici Pittsburgh.
J’étais très intéressée par ces systèmes vraiment complexes.
Nous pensions que peut-être l’oxyde nitrique affectait la mort des cellules,
comment les cellules survivent et leur résistance à d'autres choses.
J’ai commencé à travailler sur la culture de cellule, à faire grandir des cellules,
ensuite j’utilisais des souris knock-out --
des souris qui n’avaient pas le gène.
Nous avons travaillé sur ce mécanisme, qui – l’oxyde nitrique aidait les cellules à survivre.
Je me suis ensuite installé à Edimbourg.
À Edimbourg, l’animal expérimental qui est utilisé est l’étudiant en médecine.
C’est une espèce proche de l’Homme,
avec plusieurs avantages en comparaison à la souris :
ils sont gratuits, on n’a pas besoin de les raser, ils se nourrissent seuls,
et personne ne s’introduit dans votre bureau en disant
« Sauvez les étudiants de laboratoire »
C’est un modèle vraiment parfait.
Mais nous n’avons pas pu
reproduire chez l’homme ce que nous avions montré chez la souris.
Nous ne pouvions pas arrêter la production
d’oxyde nitrique dans la peau des humains.
Nous avons utilisé des crèmes qui bloquent l’enzyme productrice,
nous avons injecté des trucs. On ne pouvait pas arrêter l’oxyde nitrique.
Après 2 ou 3 années de travail, il s’est avéré que la raison à cela,
était que notre peau contient de gros stocks,
non pas d’oxyde nitrique, parce que c’est un gaz
et lorsqu’il est relâché – poof ! – et en quelques secondes il disparaît,
mais il se trouve sous ces formes :
nitrate NO3, nitrite NO2, thionitrites.
Ceux-ci sont plus stables
et ainsi votre peau a des grandes réserves d’oxyde nitrique.
Nous nous sommes dit, qu’avec ces grosses réserves,
je me demande si le soleil pouvais activer ces stocks
et les libérer de la peau,
où les stocks sont près de 10 fois plus élevés que ce que l’on a dans le système sanguin.
Est-ce que le soleil pourrait activer ces stocks dans la circulation,
et là dans le système sanguin faire de bonnes choses à notre système cardiovasculaire ?
Je suis un dermatologue expérimental,
nous avons donc penser
qu'il fallait exposer nos animaux expérimentaux au soleil.
C’est donc ce qu’on a fait, nous avons pris des volontaires
et nous les avons exposés à des UV.
Ce sont des sortes de lampe UV.
Maintenant, nous faisions très attention,
la vitamine D est produite par les rayons UV B
et nous voulions distinguer notre histoire de l’histoire de la vitamine D.
Donc nous avons utilisé des UV A, qui ne produisent pas de vitamine D.
Lorsque nous placions les gens sous une lampe
pendant l’équivalent de 30 minutes de soleil à Edimbourg,
nous avons provoqué une augmentation
de l’oxyde nitrique circulant.
Nous avons mis des patients avec ces individus sous les UV,
et leur niveau d'oxyde nitrique a augmenté,
et leur pression sanguine a diminué.
Pas de beaucoup, au niveau individuel,
mais assez au niveau de la population
pour modifier le taux de maladie cardiaque dans l’ensemble de la population.
Lorsqu’on les exposait à des UV,
ou lorsqu’on les réchauffait autant que ces lampes,
mais sans les exposer réellement au rayon qui touche la peau, ça n’arrivait pas.
Les rayons ultra-violets touchant la peau étaient donc en cause.
Actuellement, nous collectons toujours les résultats.
Quelques bonnes perspectives ici :
Apparemment, cela semble plus marqué chez les personnes âgées.
Je ne sais pas de combien exactement.
Un des sujets était ma belle-mère,
et clairement, je ne connais pas son âge.
Mais de manière évidente chez les personnes plus âgées que ma femme,
cet effet est plus marqué.
Ce que je voudrais également mentionner
c’est que ça ne change rien à la vitamine D.
C’est séparé de la vitamine D.
Donc la vitamine D est bonne pour vous, ça évite le rachitisme,
protège le métabolisme du calcium, des choses importantes.
Mais c’est un mécanisme séparé de la vitamine D.
Ensuite, un des problèmes quand on regarde la pression sanguine,
c’est que votre corps fait tout ce qu’il peut
pour maintenir la pression sanguine au même niveau.
Si votre jambe est coupée et que vous perdez du sang,
votre corps va se réprimer, augmentant la fréquence cardiaque,
et faire tout ce qu’il peut pour maintenir la pression sanguine.
C’est un principe physiologique absolument fondamental.
Alors ce que nous avons fait ensuite
c’est étudier la dilatation des vaisseaux sanguins.
Donc on l’a mesuré -- ceci est,
on peut le voir à l’absence de queue et de poil, ceci est un étudiant en médecine.
Au niveau du bras, on peut mesurer le flux sanguin
en évaluant le gonflement du bras au fur et à mesure que le flux y entre.
Ce que nous avons montré c’est qu’en faisant une irradiation simulée —
c’est la ligne épaisse ici --
ce sont des rayonnements UV sur le bras, ça chauffe
mais en le couvrant les rayons n’atteignent pas la peau.
Il n’y a pas de changement de flux sanguin, de dilatation des vaisseaux sanguins.
Mais la radiation active,
pendant l’UV et encore une heure après,
il y a dilatation des vaisseaux sanguins.
C’est le mécanisme par lequel vous diminuez la pression sanguine,
par lequel vous dilatez aussi les artères coronaires,
pour laisser le sang arriver au cœur.
Donc ici, des données supplémentaires sur les ultraviolets – c’est du rayonnement solaire --
a des bénéfices sur le flux sanguin et le système cardio-vasculaire.
On pensait avoir modélisé –
différentes quantités d’UV touchant différentes parties de la Terre à différents moments de l’année,
on peut donc vraiment travailler sur ces stocks d’oxyde nitrique
– les nitrates, nitrites, thionitrites dans la peau –
se dissocier pour relâcher de l’oxyde nitrique.
Différentes longueurs d’onde ont différentes actions sur ce phénomène.
On peut regarder les longueurs d’onde qui font ça.
Et on peut regarder – Donc si vous vivez à l’équateur, le soleil arrive droit au-dessus,
il traverse une couche très fine d’atmosphère.
En hiver ou en été, c’est la même quantité de lumière.
Si vous vivez ici, en été
le soleil arrive presque tout à fait directement,
mais en hiver, il traverse une couche épaisse d’atmosphère,
et la plupart des ultra-violets est éliminée,
donc la gamme de longueur d’onde qui touche la Terre
est différente en été et en hiver.
Ce qu’on peut dire c’est qu’en multipliant ces données
par la quantité d’oxyde nitrique qui est relâché,
on peut calculer combien d’oxyde nitrique
serait relâché de la peau vers la circulation.
Maintenant, si vous êtes à l’équateur ici –
ce sont ces deux lignes ici, la rouge et la violette –
la quantité d’oxyde nitrique relâché est la zone sous la courbe,
c’est la zone dans l’espace ici.
Donc si vous êtes à l’équateur, en décembre ou juin,
vous avez de grandes quantités d’oxyde nitrique relâché par la peau.
Ventura est en Californie du sud.
En été vous pourriez être au même niveau que l’équateur.
C’est bien. Beaucoup d’oxyde nitrique est relâché.
Ventura au milieu de l’hiver, et bien, c’est une quantité satisfaisante.
Edimbourg en été, la zone sous la courbe est plutôt bonne,
mais Edimbourg en hiver, la quantité d’oxyde nitrique qui peut être libérée
est proche de zéro, de très faibles quantités.
Qu’est-ce qu’on en pense ?
On travaille toujours sur ce sujet,
on le développe toujours, on continue à l’étendre.
On pense que c’est très important.
On pense que ça intervient beaucoup dans la différence nord-sud en Angleterre,
Pour nous c'est pertinent.
On pense que la peau --
bon on sait que la peau a de grandes quantités
d’oxyde nitrique sous des formes très variées.
On suppose que la plupart provient du régime alimentaire,
les légumes verts à feuille, les betteraves, la laitue
contiennent beaucoup de ces oxydes nitriques qui vont directement dans la peau.
On pense qu’ils sont stockés dans la peau,
et on pense que les rayons du soleil les libèrent
là où ils ont généralement des effets bénéfiques.
C’est un travail toujours en cours, mais les dermatologues
– je suis un dermatologue.
Mon travail quotidien est de dire aux gens « Vous avez un cancer de la peau,
c’est à cause du soleil, ne vous exposez pas au soleil. »
Mais en réalité je pense qu’il y a un message bien plus important
c’est qu’il y a des bénéfices et des risques à l’exposition au soleil.
Oui, les rayonnements constituent le facteur de risque d’altération majeur pour les cancers de la peau,
mais les décès par maladies cardiaques sont cent fois plus nombreux
que les décès par cancer de la peau.
Je pense que nous avons besoin d’en être plus conscient,
et nous devons trouver le ratio risque / bénéfice.
Quelle exposition au soleil est sûre,
et comment pouvons-nous l’optimiser pour notre santé globale ?
Merci beaucoup,
(Applaudissements)